so Robert let's get right into so is
this a pandemic or is this a planned
emic well I you know that's a hard
question to answer because you know
we're dealing with a totalitarian regime
if we had perfect knowledge of what the
Chinese Communist Party's plans were I
think we could answer that but you know
we have to intuit
based on what facts we do have so we do
know for example that there's a p4 lab
in Wuhan that lab a researcher was doing
gain-of-function research on bat related
corona viruses and published a paper on
that and that paper talked about the
ability to infect humans we do know that
we also know that on January 7th the
w-h-o met in Geneva and talked about the
fact that there was human to human
transmission going on and in fact we
also know that in Wuhan they knew in
December there was human to human
transmission and of course we also know
that Xi Jinping met with the stand the
Politburo Standing Committee where they
and he talked about taking control of
the of the the growing pandemic at on
the 7th of January so we know that he
knew that they had human to human
transmission and so and let me revise
that on the 23rd of January the w-h-o
met in Geneva and talked about human to
human transmission on the somewhere
around the 22nd or 23rd of January we
know that Wuhan was locked down and at
that time the Wuhan mayor made a
statement that already five million
people from Chinese New Year's had left
the city to the four corners of the
earth so what we know is they were doing
work on the virus we don't know if
that's where it came from or if it came
from the wet market and we can't know
that because the
Chinese Communist Party's not going to
allow us into the lab they're not going
to allow us to talk to the researchers
all the data has been sprout we don't
know what we do know for a fact is both
the Chinese Communist Party leadership
and the whu-oh leadership knew there was
human human transmission prior to the
five million people leaving when they
locked down on so planned emic pandemic
I don't know but in terms of the origin
of virus I do know that in terms of the
pandemic itself you could call that a
plan Demick because they knew that there
was human human transmission and they
let those people leave and you know the
president acted quickly to shut down
flights to and from China and thank God
he did the problem is that we kept them
coming from Europe so you see the big
infection happening in New York because
of travel coming to and from Europe
where the Chinese people that had left
Wuhan went into Europe and created the
infections of that spread to New York